And so I think it makes sense for us to look for ways
to mitigate that impact.
And we need to do research to do that.
We need to understand the science behind that.
I've noticed that there's a theme that's kind of developed at TED,
which is kind of, "fear versus hope,"
or "creativity versus caution."
And of course, we need both of those.
So there aren't any silver bullets.
This is certainly not a silver bullet.
But we need science to tell us what our options are;
that informs both our creativity and our caution.
So I am an optimist about our future selves,
but I'm not an optimist because I think our problems are small.
I'm an optimist because I think our capacity to deal with our problems
is much greater than we imagine.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)
This talk sparked a lot of controversy at TED2017,
and we encourage you to look at discussions online
to see other points of view.